So Implicit memory is also called non-declarative memory because we can not
directly recall this type of memory. Implicit memory is a kind of memory that's
made up of knowledge based on previous experiences such as skills that we
preform automatically once you have mastered them. Implicit memory resides
outside of our conscience awareness. So for implicit memory, we know how to do
something, for example ride a bike, but it's difficult to describe how we can
preform the skills we know how to do so well. For example, I know how to scuba
dive, and I love to dive, but it's difficult for me to describe how you swim
through the water. Make sure you're weighted right, have to inflate or deflate
your bcd, it's something you have to experience for yourself. On the other
hand, Susan knows how to knit and she can knit really pretty scarves, but if
you ask her how to explain it or give you step by step instructions like I
have, it's hard for her to do that. So for the example of Susan and knowing how
to knit, she needs to know where her fingers belong, where the needles go and
how to move the yarn around. This is an example of procedural memory. So
procedural memory refers to the knowledge we hold for almost any behavior or
physical skill we've learned. Again this could be things like driving a manual
transmission car, knitting, scuba diving, playing hockey or any sport. Priming
is another type of Implicit memory. Priming occurs when recall is improved by
prior exposure to the same or similar stimuli. In fact memory is better for
information that relates to prior knowledge.